Gamma would never forget the horrific sight
of SCP-5967.
On the surface, she kept her nerve; cool and
collected, her finger ready to squeeze the
trigger as her weapon stayed trained on the
entity.
But deep down, it turned her stomach.
After all, how is someone meant to react when
they see a thing like that?
A mess of flesh and eyeballs towering above
them, staring back through more retinas than
any living creature has.
She didn’t yet know it, but she’d be seeing
that disgusting pillar of musculature and
eyes in her nightmares for months to come.
And still, it wasn’t even the worst part
of the incursion.
Far worse than seeing the five-meter tall
eyeball totem, watching it blink its many
lids at her, was witnessing what it had done
to Alpha.
Only moments before, Gamma’s commanding
officer had been in control of the situation,
leading Mobile Task Force Lambda-5 into the
meadowlands of East Rutherford, New Jersey.
The mission should have been a simple smash
and grab, the same old boring story their
team had lived through countless times before.
Pick up a high-value target, the leader of
yet another cult practicing an anomalous religion,
and bring him in for questioning.
Gamma never could’ve expected that things
would go this badly.
The task force had arrived to discover Caesar
Winters, the leader of a sect of Fifthists
operating in New Jersey.
When Lambda-5 discovered him, Winters and
his followers - locals who were all members
of a group known as ‘the Commune’ - were
standing in a circle around an instance of
SCP-5967.
Standing at around five meters in height,
SCP-5967s were piles comprised of mostly musculature
and organs that resembled eyeballs…
human eyeballs.
Despite lacking a mouth, vocal cords, or any
other conventional methods of speech, these
pillars could still very much communicate
verbally.
Although, they had little to say besides spouting
phrases and principles associated with the
Fifthist ideology.
Almost immediately, the plan to capture Winters
had gone awry.
It was almost like he expected the Foundation
to arrive…
like he knew they were coming.
As the members of MTF Lambda-5 moved in, keeping
Winters in their sights, the anomalous cult
leader somehow turned the gaze of SCP-5967
onto Alpha.
The team’s field commander ordered Delta
to open fire, taking out Caesar Winters in
a single shot… but only for a moment.
Another of the Commune members keeled over
and began convulsing.
A wound formed at the person’s neck, and
from it emerged Caesar Winters’ face.
It grew into a full-sized head, replacing
that of the Commune member, giving Winters
a brand new body in moments.
On Alpha’s orders, to stop Winters from
hopping to more new bodies, Gamma and the
others in their team fired on the other cultists.
Everyone was terminated, fifteen seconds was
all it took.
Then they moved towards SCP-5967… and everything
went wrong.
The bodies started to convulse violently,
as if some unseen hand was shaking them around
like ragdolls.
Gamma watched as they began to levitate, hoisted
by their necks and floating towards the Mobile
Task Force.
Not one of them knew what to do, keeping their
rifles up and trained on the corpses.
Each one folded in on itself, becoming compressed
masses of muscle embedded with eyes.
That was when the team lost Alpha.
Something was happening to their leader, she
had dropped her weapon and fallen to her knees.
Immediately, Gamma moved in to help her commander,
trying to pull her back to her feet.
But Alpha was resisting, transfixed by SCP-5967.
“It’s Her.
She is lost deep in the cosmos and is angry
with us for not helping Her find Her way back.
She will kill us all, lest we line our brains
and see Her for who She truly is!”
Gamma watched as her team’s leader rushed
towards the pillar of eyes and licked it.
The floating orbs of flesh and eyes that had
once been people suddenly hurtled towards
the members of MTF Lambda-5 at high speed.
Gamma dove clear at the vital moment, performing
a tactical roll and managing to narrowly avoid
being struck.
Beta wasn’t so lucky.
Ready to retaliate, Gamma raises a weapon
to fire at the floating remains, only to hear
Alpha ordering her to stop.
She had stopped licking SCP-5967, but whatever
influence had compromised the Mobile Task
Force leader hadn’t relinquished its hold
over her.
She grinned unnervingly as her eyes rolled
back into her head.
“Don't you hear Her voice?
She is angry.
But I can save you.
I can save us.
Let me show you,” Alpha said, before charging
at Gamma with her arms outstretched.
In seconds, before she could defend against
her commanding officer, Gamma found herself
pounced upon by Alpha.
Grabbing a nearby rock, Alpha swung it at
her head and knocked Gamma’s tactical helmet
clean off.
Pinning her down, possessed by some unknown
anomalous entity, Alpha held open Gamma’s
eyelids… and licked her eyeball.
Gamma screamed in horror, as Alpha looked
up to the sky and yelled:
“I can see you!
I can see everything now!”
The case of SCP-5967 is one of the stranger
tales within the annuls of the SCP Foundation’s
history.
Their investigation that led to the discovery
of these five-foot-tall pillars of eyes and
muscle originally began with a different intention.
The Commune had been making waves in Lyndhurst,
New Jersey, the kind of waves that had caught
the SCP Foundation’s attention.
The two leaders of this apparent cult were
Salem Steros and Caesar Winters, both of whom
seemed to be able to use SCP-5967’s to take
control of the local residents’ minds.
Anyone that they affected could be controlled
remotely by either Steros or Winters, with
a seemingly unlimited range and no known way
of relinquishing their control over an affected
person.
Amnestic treatments, hypnotherapy, none of
the Foundation’s usual methods worked.
Undercover Foundation operatives working secretly
within the Lyndhurst Police Department were
the first to discover an instance of SCP-5967,
right under their noses.
Literally, the pillar of eyeballs seemed to
have sprouted up right in the middle of the
Lyndhurst Police Station.
The Foundation sent in containment teams to
secure the area and administer amnestics to
witnesses.
But just how were Steros and Winters causing
these monstrous musculature monoliths to appear?
Well, the pair operated a radio show together,
known as The Reality Cinq.
However, the Foundation agents within Lyndhurst
had been unable to track down exactly where
they were broadcasting from.
However, after the SCP-5967 instance appeared
within the police station, the answer seemed
to present itself.
During the building’s reconstruction, tapes
of their radio show were recovered, seeming
to suggest that the pair had been utilizing
anomalous means to broadcast The Reality Cinq
from within the station itself, while keeping
themselves concealed.
The Reality Cinq was a religious talk show,
specifically focused on discussing elements
of Fifthism with the audience and callers
who phoned into Winters and Steros’ hidden
studio.
What exactly is Fifthism?
Well, there’s no easy answer to that question
unfortunately.
Other anomalous cults and religions at least
have a core tenet or belief at their center.
Sarkicism is the worship of disease and decay,
while Mekhanites from the Church of the Broken
God venerate technology.
The beliefs of the Fifth Church are a little
more interchangeable, however.
They don't really have any defined theology
or religious practices.
Fifthism is often more just a collection of
recurring ideas and motifs; the number five,
stars, and the belief in an external cosmic
god, often a malicious one.
In fact, if there is a defining principle
of Fifthism, it’s that it is an anomalous
way of thinking that can’t really be understood.
Practitioners of Fifthism are concerned primarily
with transcending reality, as we perceive
it.
They are highly interested in entities and
anomalies that can warp and shape reality,
to the extent of even being fearful of such
beings.
A lot of Fifthists seek to not only spread
their influence to others through any means
necessary - including brainwashing - but also
hope to transcend humanity to a higher plane
reality: the Fifth Dimension.
There, in theory, a person would cease to
be a human being, and wouldn’t even really
be akin to a god or powerful reality bender.
Instead, they would become something more
vague, a concept, unable to be fully defined
or to exist in reality completely.
Fifthists follow this goal, presumably with
the intention of saving humankind from reality-warping
anomalies.
And they’ll use any infectious brainwashing
methods at their disposal to bring as many
people as they can into their way of thinking.
This brings us neatly back to Caesar Winters
and Salem Steros’ radio show, the Reality
Cinq.
This was the Commune’s - their particular
sect of Fifthism - way of spreading what they
referred to as the truth.
Based on the various fragmented cassette recordings
of their show that the SCP Foundation were
able to recover, both Steros and Winters believed
in a many-armed goddess, referred to only
as She or Her.
They encouraged their listeners to pray to
this entity and let Her know that they were
loyal to Her.
During one of their recovered broadcasts,
the pair of Fifthist hosts were even able
to prank call the SCP Foundation itself.
A Junior Researcher Jones was contacted by
the two men and ridiculed for his association
with the SCP Foundation.
But after a few jokes at Junior Researcher
Jones’s expense, Steros and Winters began
to insidiously implant ideas of Fifthism in
the researcher’s head.
They referred to this as giving Jones ‘the
Truth’, something they both intended to
do for all their listeners in order to save
them.
When asked what they meant, Winters and Steros
made vague allusions to the Truth being an
infinite knowledge that only She could bestow.
Jones had no idea who She was meant to be.
“Our guiding light?
Our creator?”
Salem described, before adding, “The very
thoughts that should be infiltrating your
head right now?”
It seemed that, through this call, the two
hosts had managed to successfully imbed their
Fifthist concepts into the mind of Junior
Researcher Jones.
And they weren’t about to stop there.
During another call on their show, both hosts
spoke with a Wallington, New Jersey resident
named Wendy Ricefield, who was already a self-proclaimed
Fifthist.
Steros and Winters talked Wendy through a
ritual to learn the Truth, involving her drawing
sigils on the walls and floor of her home,
and lighting candles.
The phone line picked up wet squelching noises
coming from the other side, the splintering
of wood, and Wendy screaming for help as she
tried to run from her home…
only for something to drag her back inside.
Eventually, the Foundation made the executive
decision to step in and deal with the situation
in New Jersey directly.
Steros and Winters’ operation was getting
out of hand, more and more people in the surrounding
area were being brainwashed into believing
in Fifthist concepts, and compelled to complete
bizarre rituals.
Sending a team in to apprehend the cult leaders,
Foundation personnel discovered Salem Steros
and numerous other members of the Commune.
They had gathered at an instance of SCP-5967
that had manifested in Wallington… the same
place that Wendy Ricefield had been from.
Steros and his Fifthist followers were discovered
holding hands and standing in a circle around
the anomalous pillar of eyeballs, as well
as approaching it and… licking SCP-5967.
The members of the Commune were rounded up,
and most were sent to be kept in isolation
at Site-9.
However, Salem Steros was brought to Site-83
for questioning.
Junior Researcher Umar Hadid conducted an
interview as to the exact nature of the goddess
Her that Steros and Winters often referred
to, and the anomalous rituals the pair had
been involved with.
Salem was less than co-operative, He demanded
to be set free in the interest of saving people
by spreading the Truth with Caesar.
However, he did reveal some key information
about Her.
According to Steros’ claims, She was a goddess
actively meddling with reality and influencing
human actions.
He told Hadid that if he killed the Junior
Researcher right there, it would be because
She willed it.
Sometime before, both Salem and his cult co-leader
Caesar had been stargazing in the meadowlands,
a remote field in East Rutherford.
That’s when they had allegedly heard Her
voice, and been told the Truth.
This reality-warping goddess was intending
to return home, but that way back was broken.
So, according to Steros, she needed their
help.
This was the reason he and Winters began creating
instances of SCP-5967 - the eyeball pillars
apparently acted as beacons, like a GPS signal
allowing Her to come back.
The pair and the rest of the Commune were
attempting to prove their loyalty to Her,
in the hopes that they would potentially be
allowed to transcend reality, in accordance
with the Fifthist principle.
Salem Steros was remanded into SCP Foundation
custody, and kept detained in a containment
suite surrounded by three Scranton Reality
Anchors.
Shortly after, the members of MTF Lambda-5
were dispatched, heading to the location Steros
had inadvertently revealed during his interrogation.
Their mission was to arrest Caesar Winters…
who remained at large after the leader of
Lambda-5 was compromised.
Eventually, Gamma was able to contact the
Foundation, who sent a containment team as
backup.
They secured the surviving MTF operative,
along with the infected team leader Alpha
and the instance of SCP-5967 on the scene.
Gamma was offered medical treatment and presented
with a Silver Lion badge for her efforts in
the field, along with a two-week vacation
as a reward.
That did little to stop the nightmares, though;
she wasn’t the same.
And neither was Alpha.
After two long weeks of psychological screening,
and no further hostile or anomalous activity,
Alpha was interviewed by Junior Researcher
Hadid.
During their discussion, Alpha - real name
Cassandra ‘Sandy’ Dankofski - described
that she could still hear a voice in her head,
rambling about the Truth, Fifthism, and eyeballs.
Amnestic treatment wasn’t helping.
Suddenly, someone within the Foundation played
a clip of Casear Winters’ voice over the
facility speakers, taken from one of his and
Steros’ radio broadcasts.
It triggered an instant paranoid reaction
from Sandy, followed by her opening her mouth
and revealing something growing inside - Another
eyeball.
Some kind of post-hypnotic suggestion, or
other form of brainwashing had affected her,
and she began exhibiting anomalous behavior.
“Tell me, Hadid, are you a Fifthist now?”
she asked the Junior Researcher.
“Are you ready to see the Truth?”
Hadid rushed out of the room, shutting the
door behind him.
Pacing around the room, Sandy started drawing
strange sigils of unknown origin on the floor
and walls, lighting a candle through anomalous
means.
There then came a bright flash of light, as
a four-legged entity appeared and attacked
Alpha.
The two merged, causing her body to change
until it was unrecognizable.
Well, as human, anyway.
Standing in the interrogation room where Sandy
had been standing, was a contorted mass of
flesh and muscle, with multiple eyeballs staring
out from it.
She had turned into another instance of SCP-5967.
They all had.
They were people.
Steros and Winters had made beacons out of
living people…
Now check out “SCP-3760 - LIKE A DOLL'S
EYES” and “THE EYE PODS - SCP-131” for
more!